okay more now on the legal changes in
Israel I want to bring you some live
pictures from West Jerusalem thousands
of protests have been Gathering near the
Israeli Parliament after that decision
was made earlier on in the last few
hours or so the United States is
watching the developments in Israel
Kimberly Hawkins is live for us in
Washington D.C how is the White House
reacting to all of its Kimberly
we've had statements from the National
Security Council part of the White House
as well as the state department both
speaking from the same sheet of music
and what they're essentially saying is
that the feeling is from the bite
Administration that it's unfortunate
this vote took place you'll have to
remember that the president himself
actually sent out a statement just hours
before the vote urging the prime
minister to change his mind that did not
happen and now the feeling is that it's
unfortunate this went ahead and really
essentially moved ahead with the
slimmest possible majority now when it
comes to these kinds of changes the view
of the White House is that this needs to
be done with uh consensus when there is
democratic change and that is not what
the White House is seeing on the ground
just the opposite as demonstrated by the
fact that there are thousands taking to
the streets in protest it is the view of
the White House that this is really
divided the Israeli population and so
that is of grave concern to the United
States so the statement that is being
issued is one that it's really a feeling
that there is a need for the Israeli
leaders to work together to find some
consensus and the feeling is is that
this can only be brought about through
political dialogue Kimberly president
Isaac Herzog of Israel was in uh the U.S
just a few days ago talking to president
uh Biden Biden has also invited Benjamin
Netanyahu after some lengthy delayed to
go to the White House to to talk to him
Israel is an important factor in any U.S
election how is this playing out in U.S
politics
well what this has done is not just
divided the population in Israel it's
divided the American population to some
extent uh certainly the uh diaspora here
in the United States but also the
population in terms of the politicians
on Capitol Hill what we've always seen
is kind of an iron-clad support for
Israel in the U.S Congress and already
we've seen that fracturing it began with
the concern about the expansion of
Jewish settlements in the occupied West
Bank and this is only exacerbated things
the plan for judicial reform by Benjamin
Netanyahu there were very vocal uh Ops
opposition by members of the democratic
party who urged President Biden to do
more to try and prevent this and we've
only seen the piling on of that of late
so what we've seen is the president
delaying because of some of these
policies of what he considers to be the
most extreme right-wing Coalition since
the 1970s a delaying of a meeting that
is customary between the Israeli leader
and the U.S president since Benjamin
Netanyahu came into office in December
now of course that has been extended as
an invitation as of last week but not to
the White House where in fact we're not
sure when this is going to happen and
where it could even be on the sidelines
of the U.N general assembly in the fall
so that is delivered it's sending a
message that the White House doesn't
like what's going on and it feels that
its partner or that is shared view of
democracy uh is veering in the wrong
direction and that's the message that is
being sent yeah it's those subtle
differences that there are very
significant Kimberly thank you very much
indeed for explaining that to us well
joining us live from Brooklyn New York
is Libby linkinski she's the vice
president for public engagement at the
new Israel fund thank you very much
indeed for being with us Kimberly was
just describing to us the kind of
Divisions this is creating on Capitol
Hill plus the kind of Divisions that are
being seen amongst American voters and
American Israeli supporters Israel
supporters as well what's the reaction
amongst your members to what's been
going on
completely well as you may know New
Israel fund and our tens of thousands of
supporters around the country and the
world have always been an engine of
progressive Civil Society of liberal
democracy in Israel so this struggle is
not new for us though it is certainly
reaching New Heights as this extreme
right-wing government led by Netanyahu
is pushing to truly dismantle the
divisions of power that do exist within
Israeli democracy and including today so
we are against what is going on we are
in solidarity with the hundreds and
thousands of Israelis who are Marching
today and we are in solidarity and in
great support of hundreds of progressive
non-profits that are pushing for True
democracy for all Israelis and those
living under Israel's control
the Prime Minister Netanyahu himself has
a very strong support base within the
United States as does the Israel itself
and as does the Israeli government at
least in previous iterations having said
all of that from your point of view how
are you detecting any shifts in
um emphasis or shifts in support from
people who would normally be staunchly
behind Benjamin Netanyahu and the
Israeli government
absolutely I mean we know from public
opinion research that between 70 and 80
percent of American Jews uh largely
self-identify as liberal and vote
Democrat in American elections what
we're seeing in Israel right now is
antithetical to those values so we are
seeing
um voices in American Jewish leadership
and on the streets here uh coming out
not to undo their support for Israel but
to change what it actually means to
support the Israel that they know and
love to support the Israel that we know
and love means to oppose what this
government is doing now for myself and
for many supporters of the new Israel
fund it goes far beyond this this
judicial coup we believe that there can
be no democracy while there's occupation
we believe in equal rights for all but
what is right in front of us all of us
who are watching and all of us who are
there on the ground uh is an
unprecedented act against democracy and
so we are seeing uh an outpouring of
voices from North America and from
around the world and including on the
streets in Israel against this judicial
coup just very briefly this is only the
first part of a series of proposals that
are going to be put forward in terms of
changing the legal process what are your
expectations for democracy in Israel
should they all be accepted and all go
ahead
well I think what we're seeing on the
streets is that large parts of the
Israeli population are not going to
stand for these kinds of changes and so
if this first peg this first legislative
Peg is any indication uh I think we are
looking at Big struggles ahead and I
want to say that while today's news may
have sent shock waves through some parts
of the world it this is not the time to
despair those of us who want to see
Israel thriving as a democracy need to
take this opportunity for organizing the
broadest possible Coalition on the
ground and around the world that we can
to defeat these extreme right-wing
elements from my perspective we need to
expand what that pro-democracy camp
looks like to include all those people
living in Israel and under Israel's
control and all the people who support
them but right now the first step is to
um
uh undo some of the harm that's already
being planned and that has already been
voted in today Libby Lang Kinski we
appreciate you being with us on Al
Jazeera thank you very much indeed for
your time
thank you for having me